Oh check the sound like the what -
called um what is such a freaking door
I'm sorry
cartoon hi guys my name is gray sobbing
I did not know now you know your life is
different now
one grace helbig's channel been trying
and trying and trying for month to make
a club happen ever in town no courage
Hampton with Los Angeles no incoming
green juice with me and then throw it in
the garbage because it actually tastes
like yeah it's not very good but Thomas
is a new friend so I thought that we
would play the newly friend game hey if
you do not know the newly friend game is
basically a combination of the newlywed
game and just friendship wholesome fun
we'll see I think we have like seven
questions that we've each answered for
ourselves and we've written our answers
down so now we're going to go through
each question and try to guess what the
other person's answer is in an attempt
to know each other on it and you are
really good at explaining things
Oh taking me ten times to do I blacked
out in the middle so do you feel good
about your question your answers I
believe so yeah there's some deeper
questions in here some surface questions
in here so let's start surface let start
with our favorite color wine nut paper
don't show us sorry I'm not showing
showing okay
I think yes your favorite color all
right I think your favorite color is
yellow Wow yellow yeah I don't want to
yell oh I think yellow because you seem
like a bright person oh that is bold and
brave and not afraid to really be bright
no I I wish my coat my favorite color
was yellow it was actually red red oh
it's stinking red really yeah that's how
I pronounce red yeah
okay what do you think my favorite color
is something strikes me that your
favorite color would be purple oh one of
my least favorite oh I'm already off to
a great start growing up of the tomboy
and so I didn't like purple or Pink's I
don't know why but for some reason my
favorite color is navy blue really navy
blue it feels like it just got to be
together and that's something I strive
for constantly here's the fun thing
about the newlywed game anyway I mean
the newly transported flip let's do a
favorite movie you love Disney is gonna
say I'm gonna go with Lion King whoa you
are so close you're so close it was
Aladdin Aladdin so like that was like
one year off Aladdin was 1983 lion Kings
1994 classic yeah my choice is it's kind
of like a miniseries Oh miniseries I
know that doesn't help at all if
anything I mix this answer way more
complicated Lord of the Rings no no you
could say it's the documentary version
of that it's making a murderer
oh my goodness what are you serious I
mean I love documentary it was really
good it was so addictive when I first
started watching it was up till 4:00
a.m. yeah finish it and they're coming
back with more so I'm all in your celeb
crush yes I think is Emma Watson oh my
goodness
well she's definitely up there Watson
I'm definitely gonna give you a
half-point for them
yeah I chosen daya she's just so she's
so she's lawless human being I was tied
between zendaya and hayden Panettiere oh
I've had the crab had a crush on hayden
Panettiere for the longest lines and
daya just gorgeous okay who do you think
my celebrity crush is Chris Hemsworth oh
yeah that's definitely in the mix is it
is it like a superhero yeah esque it is
chris evans no but also could be in the
mix could be in the name Chris Pratt one
of the Chris's no but that's that's a
very Holy Trinity of Christmas no it's
here it's Grant Gustin it plays the
flash cute I think your pet peeve is um
when people judge you without knowing
you well shoot that's actually a really
good one
now did you say that I think a lot of
people know me from the vines that I
made yeah and so I think that's where
like people tied my identity to so
that's a good that's a good one okay but
what attorney Commons nowhere near as
philosophical as that I put I put
cracking knuckles okay so yours when
people expect you to do things in the
morning when you're not ready oh that's
a good one
no mine in general just kind of bullying
oh yeah I don't like when people know
that they're hurting someone's feelings
and they don't like change the way
they're operating oh yeah I think one of
your most embarrassing moments is you um
you peed your pants on stage during a
performance so close yeah that's so
close to what I wrote I lost my pants on
stage one
oh I was in a show called Heather's the
musical and there's a there's a scene in
the show where you do the do uh-huh
God doing the do you want to do yes like
the pants went flying we were supposed
to wake up and I'm supposed to get
dressed
yeah pants were gone so it's pretty
embarrassing I mean that show was that
much more memorable that so you do
comedy on stage so I feel like it's also
gonna be on stage it was sort of
performance related being a presentation
or a speech clothes I'm trying to like
usually I am I feel like okay you were
in front a whole bunch of people and you
tripped and you fell metaphorically
that's what my first celebrity interview
with the cast of Stella it's David Wain
and Michael Showalter Michael Ian Black
I've never done an interview before and
I was like what are we doing so
last-minute
and I got there's like you know just
like shooting [ __ ] then they're cool
guys bring a camera and then the
microphone and I was just like hey guys
and they were like do you have any
questions for us and I was like um no
idea what I was doing in hindsight I
must have been like the dumbest idiot to
them no and they were just like so you
don't have many questions prepared and
it literally kronos you when they real
me but then like in a sarcastic yeah I'm
assuming they were playing around I feel
like one of your biggest life goals
would be to write your own musical Wow
I think that's just me wanting you to
write your own music really once again
you're very close great mine was
basically just to be in a musical just
beyond Broadway like that's my biggest
thing
extremely attainable your mom guys
that's oh you were a life goal I want to
say like you want like a main stage like
do comedy
oh I said my biggest life goal is being
happy la la la la la
JK is starting a sweatshirt fashion line
this is favorite youtuber but with
underlying
idea that we couldn't choose each other
obviously because those would be our
first two choices
yeah I think your favorite youtuber at
the moment because it always changes
uh-huh it's Jon Cozart as a disclaimer
there's so many youtubers that I oh yeah
like that was really hard I know it's a
really mean question because it really
is
it's what the understanding that we love
everyone but at the moment right now cuz
you know flavor of the week okay so for
you
superwoman oh that is good that it and I
love Lily's videos but right now I've
been binging on kacie nice fattening oh
why did I not guess that you literally
just brought up Casey before the video
started yeah how's it gonna last name
very innovative and very interesting I
think you know me a lot more now we both
know each other yes you fun part of this
game is there is no scorekeeping because
it's just about getting to know each
other yeah thanks for being here it's
just so much hi such an honor and we
made a video over on Thomas's channel
what do we do my brain is part of fun
Google guess Oh Google gets weird you
guys gave us the start of sentences to
search in Google and we tried to guess
how Google would complete those
statements and Wow
talk about educational experience that
was a time so make sure that you guys go
over to his channel and check it out
where else should they go look at stuff
Instagram Instagram okay with all of
those links with absorption bar below do
good things with your lives I don't know
I'm still is my chess game I feel like
my chair singing I'm just - I'm just too
heavy
it's sabotaging me I love it
I'll then edit and be like you know I'm
just gonna bounce up and down